let's go next to ed
from
new hampshire ed welcome are you living
free or dying up there or what
i am living free uh mr pacman thank you
um let me just say thank you for having
me on here as a first time caller my
pleasure and i wanted to talk about um
firearms laws because i'm someone who
is a fairly pro-gun person but at the
same time
i really really hate the republican
party i grew up in a family that had
people growing up within the homosexual
community and i'm sorry but you know i
grew up in a time when the republican
party still does
actively oppress homosexuals and i can't
put myself support myself behind that
party okay now wait hold on when you say
you you grew up in a homosexual
community what does that mean
not a community i mean like a family
like i have gay cousins oh i got it i
got it okay okay okay
all right so but at the same time you
know
i i would i have a hard time voting for
the democrats because of
some of the things they they put forward
regarding gun control law okay and i'm
someone who believes that
there are some compromises both sides
can make but i actually believe that
a lot of the proposals democrats are
making
isn't
pro isn't a good way to
go across this and it's not going to
actually
make these
shootings um stop i actually think in
some cases it may actually make him
worse all right well let's dig into that
first of all when i talk about gun
violence when i talk about quote
shootings
i think there are three different types
of shootings and each has to be dealt
with separately so there's
firearms suicides there's individual
firearms homicides
individual firearms homicides and then
you've got your mass shootings am i
correct that today you want to talk
about the mass shootings right you're
not talking right now about gun suicides
or the individual homicides
um no well yeah let's uh talk about the
mass shooting thing because i do because
i because if there's one thing i hate
about the right it's the whole suicide
mentality thing is that that is one side
about the pro gun control the um pro gun
side that i absolutely deserve we want
to reduce all three of these types of
deaths but right the solutions are
different you and i are going to talk
about the mass shootings give me an
example of something democrats want to
do that you think might actually make
mass shootings worse
um for example banning the
ar-15 and when i say this it's because
of it has nothing to do with
the a with like the magazine capacity or
anything else it's that
there the chances are is that the ar-15
believe believe it or not
it's not all that high-powered of a
rifle
there are a lot of other high-powered
rifles out there
in america that mimic everything the
ar-15 does okay let me stop you there
because i think this one we might be
very easily able to resolve
the proposal i'm currently seeing would
ban all assault style rifles ar15 being
only one of them if we said assault
style rifles instead of just the ar-15
would that deal with the fact that there
are ar-15 alternatives
uh no it's because there are plenty of
other rifles out there that
function exactly the same way as the
ar-15 but are significantly older they
we're talking about weapons that date
back to the world war eras
and i just you know these are weapons
that have been out there in civilian
hands for decades right but the number
of the world war one world war ii era
guns that you're thinking of are number
one not being actively manufactured
today and number two not nearly as
widely available just by the sheer math
right oh
no that is actually not true there are
millions and millions of world war ii
firearms out there still being is still
them some of them even still being made
today um one of them being the m1
carbine which oh so you're not literal
okay so yeah now i'm getting you're
you're saying
you're not literally saying units that
have been around for 80 years you're
saying models that are being
manufactured today but have been around
a long time yes the same thing is true
for the ar-15 itself the ar-15 has been
in civilian circulation since the 60s
right but i don't know that the fact
that these
have been around for a while means
anything one way or the other i'm not
sure what what what's the point of that
what difference does that make
well the thing is is that this mass
shooting trend you know the way it's
been happening all around yeah it's a
fairly recent trend you know i mean this
isn't to say that shootings like uh
didn't happen in the 60s i mean we all
know charles women and everything like
that
however at the rate at where they're
occurring nowadays yep and uh you know
the certain definitions that uh the gva
um portrays as what is a mass shooting
which i think can be
is a little problematic in and of itself
because
um okay but hold on now you're on to it
now you're talking about how you
categorize we're all over the place
let's let's let's see if i can reign
this in okay
yeah i'm sorry about that when it comes
to
the guns
i'm with you that something has changed
in american culture right there's a
cultural issue where more people than
ever
see guns as a way to solve
grievances that they have either with
individuals or with society that's new
and i completely agree with you
but i also believe that
if at this point in time
americans are less able than ever to
behave responsibly with firearms at a
population level
that still means we've got to do
something about the guns just
even if we grant that something about
the culture has changed where now we
have so many more people willing to do
gun violence i would still want to deal
with the guns and all of the other
things as well i would take an all of
the above approach is that fair
it is fair yes um the problem
again the uh
and i love having this conversation with
you let me just say that right now
because
this is something that a lot of people
uh on the right a lot of pro-gun people
don't do and this is something that i'm
trying to champion you know sure i hang
around with a lot of pro-gun people and
i try to get them to talk to
progressive people because believe it or
not there are a lot more progressive gun
owners out there than people may oh
there are there are yeah and listen it's
reasonable to me not to want only the
right wing nuts to have the guns i mean
that makes sense so let me just say this
because we don't have unlimited time
i am with you
no one provision will solve all the
problems right like if you just say
banning the ar-15 won't solve the mass
shooting problem i'm with you that won't
solve the mass shooting problem um
restricting access to high-capacity
magazines alone won't solve the mass
shooting problem because someone can get
grab four handguns or whatever and go
okay so i'm with you 100
my approach and i laid i don't want to
do it now because i've done it so many
times i laid out a 10 or 12 point list
of all the things that i would do on the
gun side and that doesn't mean we don't
do mental health and all we do
everything but i have 10 to 12 different
things i would do which i believe
together
would dramatically reduce mass shootings
i i have seen those points and the one
point and most of the points i do agree
on oh the one point i have a problem on
is when you say
banning some guns
and that is the one area where i
have i'm very hesitant about because
should the average person be allowed to
have a shoulder mounted rpg
well people do have rpgs okay i know
people that do i i'm not saying that
anecdotally you don't know but as a
general thing should an shoulder-mounted
rpg be as widely available as a handgun
i would say so yes okay how about a how
about a blackhawk helicopter
a blackhawk helicopter hell yeah i would
love to have one of those okay how about
a howitzer how about a howitzer should
anyone be able to go and get a howitzer
i know people that have had whiskers yes
okay but that's not the question should
anyone go and be able to get a howitzer
well they can though that's the thing no
they can't you can't go i mean listen
i'm not saying you might not be able to
somehow obtain them but a howitzer is
not something you can just go to a gun
store and order
well well that well that is true right
so and is that okay is that okay that
you can i mean is your is your right to
have whatever gun you want being
restricted by the fact that you can't go
to a gun store in new hampshire and get
a howitzer
well that well that is the problem that
i'm asking you is um is not so much
whether or not it should be like
available for every gun store it's just
the fact whether or not they should be
legally allowed to buy but what i'm
asking you is
should
you be able to go to a gun store
and say hi one howitzer please do you
believe that should be the law
depending on the type of store i mean
forget about the type
should any person be able to own a
howitzer
any any person based off of the way the
second amendment is written
yeah
wow
that's crazy i've never i honestly i've
never heard anyone argue that before
even ben shapiro didn't argue that
it's uh it's a very weird the laws in
this country the reason i say this is
because i know people that legally have
bought these things
and they are just private citizens okay
so i don't i'm not aware of that so i i
can't really speak to it but i'm gonna
have to research that but ed listen i
gotta run i really appreciate the
conversation
oh this is
definitely i mean i'd love to talk more
with you but my uh headset is actually
running low on battery so great top
great timing thanks
all right ed go recharge your bluetooth
that interesting conversation i mean
anyone can just go get a howitzer and a
blackhawk helicopter that's crazy even
the most
you know fervent
uh gun people i've not heard say that
all right everybody that's it for today
we will take calls again let's take a
very short break